et ali on bouge trempant dans le team
yole comme réponse de thierry ardisson
bien alors le portrait chinois ces sites
étaient une fleur je serai à myosotis
lentilles portrait chinois celle inverse
si vous étiez un défaut je serai la plus
grande qualité de mon pire ennemi
ouais c'est pas mal ça c'est une rupture
je ne peux pas être une rupture j'ai
trouvé que j'ai pas envie d'en devenir
une injure si j'étais une injure je
serai fille de [ __ ] parce que je suis
pour la parité malade et si j'étais une
maladie je crois que serait la maladie
d'alzheimer parce que je ne pourrais pas
me souvenir que j'ai la maladie
d'alzheimer da de concorde comme ça je
fais la une de tous les journaux dans le
monde entier pendant un mois une
perversion une perversion ça c'est
difficile je crois que je serai la
zoophilie parce que j'ai jamais
rencontré une tortue d'eau ou un cochon
d'inde me refuser à 69 une guerre une
guerre dans une guerre lubrique c'est à
dire une guerre de position un vice si
j'étais un vice je serai un vice qui
englobe tous les autres vices et le sexe
parce que c'est en même temps un jeu de
hasard est une drogue
une trahison qui était une trahison très
je suis déjà une imposture jeu peut en
plus être une trahison qu une arme une
arme
si j'étais une arme attendez laissez moi
un peu et une arme
si j'étais une arme je crois que serait
la culture parce que quand j'entends le
mot revolver je sens ma culture très
bien un supplice le supplice de la
baignoire parce que j'ai envie de mourir
proprement une cicatrice une cicatrice
le nombril du monde un poison et un
poison
alors là un poison qui coule dans les
veines de georges de boudu bouche un
[ __ ] c'est un [ __ ] serait un gros
[ __ ] comme ça je pourrais sortir il
est grosse [ __ ] cellule où je suis
c'est une [ __ ] jeté une [ __ ] sur une
cape une fille capable de coucher avec
and max ouais un impôt un impôt sur le
sex-appeal comme ça je serai exonéré
ouais une panne bas une panne
d'inspiration qui frapperait tous les
écrivains qui écrivent plus vite que moi
un dictateur hitler il a écrit des
best-sellers avait investi l'air mais
j'ai pas réussi une infirmité une
infirmité michel petrucciani parce que
j'adore le jazz la nasa
guy debord parce qu'il a assassiné guy
debord un microbe un an ça me rendrait
malade d'être un microbe une plaie s'il
était une plaie je serai ouvertes toute
la nuit
un fléau le sida parce que je suis très
people un terroriste je serai d'un
terroriste écoutez je préfère sauter des
bombes que les faire sauter pas mal une
torture une torture je serai l'avenir
parce que l'avenir appartient à ceux qui
se lèvent tôt et ça c'est une torture
recevait tous une humiliation une
humiliation une humiliation
je crois que je serai une soirée avec
rocco siffredi dans une boîte échangiste
est mort celle des autres auparavant
yann moix à lissac encore chez grasset
en vie mais arrive la rentrée s'il vous
faut l'acheter qui à moitié bien alors
maintenant mesdames et messieurs c'est
le climax de cette émission vous êtes
prêts